Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, si os pregunto
por cuáles son las fronteras más calientes
del planeta, estoy seguro de que podríais
darme muchas respuestas diferentes:
Corea del Norte y Corea del Sur, India y Pakistán,
Irán e Irak, Grecia y Turquía, Venezuela
y Colombia, Azerbaiyán y Armenia…
Al fin y al cabo, ¿Quién no tiene vecinos
problemáticos?
En buena medida, gracias a ello VisualPolitik
tiene una colección de temas interminable.
Y en esta ocasión nos vamos a desplazar hasta
una frontera que se comporta casi igual que
un volcán.
Lleva décadas inactiva, dormida, sin protagonizar
grandes titulares… Pero, ahí amigos, en
los últimos tiempos ha despertado… Y de
qué forma.
(Argelia corta lazos diplomáticos con Marruecos
a medida que aumentan las tensiones)
Tampoco es que las relaciones entre ambos
vecinos dieran para mucho. La frontera que
comparten Marruecos y Argelia está cerrada
desde 1994.
Y ambos países llevan enfrentados desde mucho
tiempo antes por la ocupación que Marruecos
realizó del Sáhara Occidental.
Aún así en los últimos tiempos la tensión
ha estado creciendo y el Ministro de Exteriores
argelino incluso culpó a Marruecos de llevar
a cabo “acciones hostiles”.
Y sí, en cierta forma, es habitual que Argel
culpe a Rabat de todo lo malo que le pasa:
desde la existencia de grupos separatistas
en la región de Cabilia hasta la brutal ola
de incendios que el país ha padecido este
verano.
Pero, amigos, amigas, en esta ocasión hablamos
de algo diferente.
Así que la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es muy clara: ¿Qué ha llevado a Argelia
a cortar sus lazos diplomáticos con Marruecos?
¿Tan mal se ha portado Rabat para que su
vecino haya tomado esta decisión? ¿Hay peligro
real de que las cosas se vayan de madre y
marroquíes y argelinos terminen a tortazo
limpio?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas. Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
(LAS ARENAS OLVIDADAS)
Argelia y Marruecos nunca se han llevado bien.
Ambos países se ven como las grandes potencias
del Magreb. Y esa rivalidad siempre termina
generando fricciones.
Para colmo ambos países comparten 1.600 kilómetros
de frontera, una frontera que Francia, la
antigua potencia colonial, nunca tuvo demasiado
interés en trazar con precisión, haciendo
que la línea que separa ambos territorios
sea difusa.
Así que una de las primeras cosas que hicieron
ambos países en cuanto lograron su independencia
fue la de enviar más y más tropas a la frontera
con el objetivo de ampliar su territorio.
Así comenzó la llamada Guerra de las Arenas:
durante 1963 se produjeron numerosos choques
fronterizos que para lo único que sirvieron
fue para alimentar la rivalidad y la enemistad
entre los dos vecinos.
(Desde entonces el mayor punto de conflicto
ha estado siempre relacionado con la antigua
provincia española del Sáhara Occidental.
En 1975 Marruecos lo invadió con la Marcha
Verde y en cuestión de meses estalló una
guerra entre los invasores y el grupo independentista
del Frente Polisario.
Y a pesar de contar con el apoyo material
de Argelia, lo cierto es que los combates
no fueron nada bien para los intereses saharauis.
Las tropas de Hassan II no dudaron ni un segundo
en usar napalm y fósforo blanco, lo que provocó
la huida saharaui a los campos de refugiados
ubicados en Argelia.)
180.000 saharauis malviven desde entonces
en el área de Tinduf, una vasta llanura desértica
en pleno desierto del Sáhara.
La guerra entre Marruecos y el Polisario prosiguió
hasta que en 1989 se alcanzó una tregua gracias
a la mediación de la ONU y el acuerdo entre
ambas partes para celebrar un referéndum.
Sí, ese referéndum que nunca se celebró
y seguramente nunca lo hará. La cuestión
es que esa tregua de 1989 fue vista como una
oportunidad para el Magreb.
Y precisamente éste fue el momento en el
que se creó la UMA, la Unión del Magreb
Árabe, una organización creada para estimular
el libre comercio entre Argelia, Libia, Mauritania,
Marruecos y Túnez.
¿Y sabéis qué? El éxito fue inmediato.
Las fronteras se abrieron y se eliminaron
los controles de visado. El comercio se movía
libremente de un país a otro. Pero, amigos,
la armonía apenas duró 5 años.
La guerra civil sumió Argelia en el caos.
Y todas las esperanzas depositadas en la UMA
se desvanecieron de repente.
(En 1994 hombres armados entraron a tiros
en el hotel Atlas Asni de Marrakech, acabando
con la vida de 2 turistas españoles. Hassan
II acusó a Argelia de estar detrás del atentado
y como respuesta Marruecos expulsó repentinamente
a miles de residentes y turistas argelinos
al tiempo que volvió a exigir visados Los
generales de Argelia respondieron fortificando
y cerrando sus fronteras)
Han pasado casi 30 años y durante todo este
tiempo la frontera ha estado cerrada.
Durante años el petróleo y el gas auparon
la economía argelina. El país tenía los
recursos para financiar su desarrollo.
Pero cuando los precios de los combustibles
fósiles se desplomaron, Argelia volvió a
sumirse en el caos, especialmente desde que
en 2019 las protestas populares pusieron fin
a los 20 años de dictadura de Bouteflika.
Mientras tanto, Marruecos ha fortalecido su
posición. De hecho, el reino alauita es quién
más interés ha mostrado por reabrir la frontera.
Mohamed VI decía esto el pasado mes de julio
en su discurso del Día del Trono.
Sea como sea, no parece que esta situación
vaya a cambiar en el corto plazo. Atentos.
(NUEVAS TENSIONES Y ANTIGUAS DISPUTAS)
Hace prácticamente un año desde que el Frente
Polisario dio por concluido el alto el fuego
con Marruecos que mantenía la calma en el
Sáhara Occidental.
En VisualPolitik ya hablamos de ello. Y tal
y como muchos recordaréis la situación se
agravó cuando Estados Unidos reconoció la
soberanía marroquí sobre la antigua provincia
española.
La decisión de Trump fue una victoria para
el reino alauita y un golpe para las aspiraciones
saharauis de celebrar algún día un referéndum
de independencia.
A cambio, Marruecos tuvo que normalizar sus
relaciones diplomáticas con Israel. Y cuando
hablamos de normalizar, hablamos de dar visibilidad.
Porque la verdad es que Israel y Marruecos
siempre mantuvieron unas relaciones muy cordiales
aunque no de forma oficial. Una cordialidad
sobre la que ya quedan pocas dudas a la vista
del amplio uso que las autoridades marroquíes
han hecho del software espía israelí Pegasus.
("Project Pegasus": Algeria closely watched
by Morocco)
("Proyecto Pegasus": Argelia vigilada de cerca
por Marruecos)
6.000 números de teléfono espiaban los servicios
de inteligencia de Marruecos con el software
Pegasus.
Hablamos de casi todos los peces gordos del
país vecino: el llamado Le Pouvoir, la élite
política, económica y militar que han dominado
la República Argelina desde la independencia
del país.
Y tal y como os podéis imaginar, la implicación
de Rabat en esta trama de espionaje ha sentado
fatal en Argel.
¡Y para colmo el espionaje llega en colaboración
con Israel!
Porque, amigos, Argelia es un país donde
todo va muy lento. Y hoy por hoy sigue mostrándose
como uno de los defensores más comprometidos
con la causa palestina.
Así que Argel está acusando a Rabat de traicionar
al mundo musulmán al aliarse con el enemigo
judío. Y claro, los que de verdad están
encantados con todo este nuevo juego son los
israelíes. Porque siempre funciona la lógica
del enemigo de mi enemigo es mi amigo.
En esta misma línea, hace 3 años Rabat rompió
relaciones con Irán tras salir a la luz que
el Frente Polisario estaba recibiendo el apoyo
de Irán y de Hezbollah.
Así que, digamos, los bloques parecen definidos:
Marruecos e Israel versus Argelia e Irán.
Por eso en agosto el ministro de Exteriores
israelí visitó Marruecos y no perdió la
ocasión de echar más leña al fuego.
(Lapid - el ministro de exteriores israelí
- revela la existencia de un acercamiento
entre Argelia e Irán. Hespress)
Pero, ojo, porque todos estos renovados lazos
entre Marruecos e Israel también le viene
de perlas al gobierno de Argelia.
Y es que veréis, tal y como os comentaba
antes, la caída de los precios del petróleo
y del gas han sido terribles para la economía
del país. Especialmente porque con el dinero
del petróleo y el gas el gobierno subvencionaba
un montón de cosas.
Y, claro, en cuanto llegaron los recortes,
las protestas ciudadanas se llevaron por delante
al régimen de Bouteflika.
Pero esperad un momento, porque todo el período
postBouteflika está siendo aún peor.
Las luchas entre las diferentes facciones
de Le Pouvoir han aumentado el caos en el
país. Así que, digamos, que dirigir las
miradas contra un enemigo externo, ya sea
Marruecos o Israel, es un argumento que la
propaganda argelina estaba deseosa de poder
explotar.
¿Hasta qué punto? Bueno, pues directamente
hasta el extremo de que este verano el norte
de Argelia era literalmente un infierno. Marruecos
ofreció dos aviones contra-incendios.
¿Y cuál creéis que fue la respuesta argelina?
Pues… Antes quemarse que humillarse. Mirad.
(Oídos sordos a la oferta de ayuda de Marruecos
a Argelia, Tebboune pide ayuda europea. Moroccoworldnews)
Amigos, amigas, el tira y afloja es continuo.
Ahora bien, es evidente que las economías
de ambos países ganarían mucho si ambos
se llevaran bien. Y desde luego las cosas
en Argelia no van precisamente por el buen
camino, especialmente si hablamos de economía.
va
Así que la pregunta es, ¿A qué obedece
tanto interés por enfrentarse con Rabat?
¿Es tan solo una cuestión de propaganda
y marketing político?
Pues… Atentos.
(GAS & FURIA)
Argelia es el décimo productor mundial de
gas natural. La mitad de este gas la aprovecha
para consumo propio y la otra mitad la exporta.Y
tal y como os podéis imaginar, sus principales
clientes son europeos: un 60% del gas natural
que Argelia vende al exterior llega a Italia
o a España, en su gran mayoría a través
de gasoductos.
Pero claro, ya sabéis donde está situada
Argelia. Para que esos gasoductos sean capaces
de llegar al continente europeo, en su momento
se tuvo que negociar con los países vecinos:
Túnez para el gasoducto Transmediterráneo
y Marruecos para el gasoducto Magreb-Europa.
Y sí, la actual crisis diplomática entre
ambos países ya ha tenido consecuencias.
(En una nueva escalada, Argelia dejará de
suministrar gas a España a través de Marruecos)
Si hay algo que conecta las economías de
Argelia y Marruecos, esa cosa es sin duda
el gasoducto Magreb-Europa. 1.400 kilómetros
de tubería desde los yacimientos de Argelia
hasta Córdoba, de los que 540 kilómetros
discurren por territorio marroquí antes de
cruzar el estrecho de Gibraltar.
Fue inaugurado en 1996 y actualmente tiene
la capacidad de transportar cada año unos
10.000 millones de metros cúbicos de gas
natural.
Las negociaciones para la puesta en marcha
de este gasoducto arrancaron en 1990, justo
en ese período de 5 años en los que Marruecos
y Argelia se llevaron razonablemente bien.
Y fue un acuerdo pensado para que todas las
partes salieran ganando. España se aseguró
su principal fuente de suministro de gas al
tiempo que Argelia se enriquecía comercializando.
Pero amigos, la auténtica clave de todo está
en lo que sacó el reino alauita.
(A cambio de los derechos de tránsito del
gas hacia la Península Ibérica, Marruecos
percibe un peaje del 7% del valor del gas
exportado por esta vía. En 2019, esta cifra
no llegó a los 50 millones de euros a causa
de la caída en el precio de los combustibles,
pero en 2014, se acercó a los 200 millones.
Además, la empresa encargada de operar el
gasoducto es una compañía cuyo accionariado
comparten la española Naturgy y la portuguesa
Galp, gracias a un acuerdo de 1992 y cuya
fecha de extinción se fijó el 31 de octubre
de 2021.)
Esto quiere decir que en cuestión de días,
la propiedad del tramo marroquí del gasoducto
retornará al Estado de Marruecos.
Rabat ya había dejado caer que esperaban
obtener ahora un acuerdo aún más ventajoso.
El problema para Marruecos es que el Magreb-Europa
no es el único gasoducto que transporta el
gas argelino hacia la Península Ibérica.
En 2011 se inauguró el gasoducto submarino
Medgaz, que conecta directamente los yacimientos
argelinos de gas con la red española en Almería.
Tiene capacidad para 8.000 millones de metros
cúbicos.
Esto significa que el Medgaz por sí solo
sería insuficiente para cubrir las necesidades
de España.
Pero la estatal argelina Sonatrach ya ha movido
ficha
6(Naturgy y Sonatrach amplían un 25% la capacidad
del gasoducto Medgaz. ABC)
La ampliación del Medgaz llevará la capacidad
de exportación del gasoducto hasta los 10.000
millones de metros cúbicos. Según lo acordado
se tiene que completar antes del fin del 2021.
Aunque por si acaso, Argelia le ha asegurado
a España que en caso de retrasarse el proyecto
o necesitar más gas estaría en disposición
de suministrárselo mediante barcos con gas
natural licuado.
(Luego, otro problema para Marruecos es que
el gasoducto Magreb-Europa le proporciona
un 45% de su demanda de gas a un precio por
debajo del de mercado. Un gas natural que
también abastece de combustible a las plantas
térmicas que generan un 12% de la electricidad
del país.
Es decir, para entendernos: cortar el grifo
del gasoducto Magreb-Europa supondría para
Argelia quitarle a su vecino un suministro
energético relevante y una notable fuente
de ingresos.)
El mejor instrumento de propaganda política.
Aunque no el único.
Lo cierto es que últimamente en Argel no
pierden ocasión para meterle el dedo en el
ojo a sus vecinos. No se quizás tenga algo
que ver que eso de estimular un conflicto
suele ser la vía más empleada por políticos
de todo el mundo para esconder sus fracasos
y reforzar su liderazgo.
[Juntos contra el enemigo]
(Argelia cierra el espacio aéreo a todos
los aviones marroquíes)
Sin embargo hay dos asuntos que Argelia no
debería ignorar.
(Por un lado, el GNL es más caro que el gas
que llega por gasoducto. Por tanto, el gas
argelino perderá competitividad. Y las regasificadoras
españolas pueden recibir GNL de Argelia pero
también de cualquier otro lugar del mundo.
Ojo con que se retrase la ampliación.
Luego, por otro lado, sin el gasoducto Magreb-Europa
en funcionamiento, cualquier problema técnico
que impidiera operar al Medgaz dejaría a
Argelia sin alternativa para transportar su
gas natural hasta la Península Ibérica.
Y con ello perdería una de sus principales
fuentes de ingresos.)
Y tened presente una cosa, puede que España
tenga almacenes de gas que podrían cubrir
temporalmente cualquier falta de suministro
pero os aseguro que hoy por hoy en las arcas
argelinas no sobra un dinar. Y eso sin contar
el dinero que perderían por dejar de suministrar
a Marruecos.
En fin, el caso es que todo apunta a que toda
esta enorme tensión que se ha disparado entre
los dos vecinos puede que solo sea una argucia
argelina para reforzar su posición a la hora
de negociar el futuro del gasoducto Magreb-Europa
y evitar que Marruecos exija revisar las condiciones
que se pactaron hace 30 años.
Por tanto, aunque en VIsualPolitik seguiremos
atentos a esta cuestión, parece que por fortuna
la sangre no llegará al río… o en este
caso, a la frontera. Claro, que… Ya sabéis
cómo son estas cosas: la tensión existe
y un error o un malentendido pueden hacer
que de repente la pólvora comience a arder.
Jugar con fuego, esto es amenazas económicas
y militares, nunca suele ser una buena idea.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, pregunta para ti:
¿Creés que al final reinará la sensatez
y se alcanzara un acuerdo que en el fondo
viene bien tanto a Marruecos como a Argelia?
Dejadnos vuestras respuestas por aquí abajo
en los comentarios y ahora si este vídeo
os ha resultado interesante no olvideis darle
a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.